eu era uma pessoa muito ansiosa tinha
problemas de relacionamento e também não
me entendia e qual era o verdadeiro
centro do meu ser
a grande maioria das pessoas sofrem
assim como eu sofria muito
sem entender quem sou eu
a grande maioria das pessoas vivem na
superficialidade
assim como eu vivi durante muito tempo
uma vida superficial
eu vou mostrar pra vocês como essa
verdade com a primeira frase uma
pergunta quem é você quem é você sou
joão e você maria você
daniela érika cita
mas quem é você
eu sou fonoaudióloga
a estudante de graduação dona de casa o
comerciante
mas quem é você ó filha mulher esposa
mãe infinitos papéis será que realmente
o papel social que a gente exerce é
exatamente quem somos nós
isso não dá mais pra ficar no
superficial
a gente precisa ver um pouquinho mais
pra dentro
vamos pensar eu sou esse corpo legal
achei uma resposta ao corpo legal tá mas
quando alguém vem e pisa no meu pé
porque é que o pé que não responde é a
gente que empurra a roupa
ai que dó
se você é o seu corpo é só aqui deveria
reclamar disso não você como um ser
completo inteiro e só perder se alguma
parte do meu corpo não seria mais eu
vamos pensar como uma mesa depois que a
mesa está pronta ela não viram outra
coisa a não ser que alguém vai lá e
mexer nela e faz que você nasce você
cresce e ao longo da sua vida se
transforma num adulto e agora como
explicar que você o corpo se tantas
mudanças acontecem sendo que na mesa
nada aconteceu
talvez não seja o corpo a mente legal o
que eu penso somente em somente a gente
tem mania de acreditar que a nossa mente
mora no nosso cérebro mas talvez não
seja muito bem assim
vamos pensar numa idéia tem um prédio
bem alto e você pega e olha do alto do
prédio
que frio na barriga somente mora no
cérebro porque você sente um frio na
barriga e não no cérebro e agora a mente
também pode estar localizado em outra
parte do corpo
estou muito curiosa e comecei a
pesquisar sobre o ser humano desde a
graduação de fonoaudiologia já comecei a
pensar porque se todo mundo tem o mesmo
tanto mesmo jeito é a mesma forma todos
os mesmos órgãos porque a outra pessoa é
diferente de mim porque pensa diferente
de mim porque pra mim é uma situação
para ser tão constrangedora e uma outra
pessoa que também tem o mesmo corpo que
eu não é roupa talvez então não seja
somente vocês já repararam que a mente é
muito louca
existe uma história de começo meio e fim
pra mim
é tudo entrecortado tenho que no mercado
a e comprar um sabonete
mas chegando lá e se não tiver nós e
chocolate que legal eu gosto muito de
chocolate nesta páscoa foi tão boa e os
assuntos vão sendo dirigidos a partir de
uma frequência de um pensamento você
começou a pensar sobre uma história e
logo na sequência tum outro pensamento
correspondente correlacionado apareceu e
se a gente começa a dar a atenção para
esses pensamentos muitos novos
pensamentos viram e dessa forma a nossa
mente se torna uma mente a agitada
estâncias dade
tem um monte de pensamentos vinha na
minha mente e eu estou deixando ela
editada antes não era ditada agora eu tô
agitada
então quem sou eu logo não passa a ser a
minha mente
bom eu não sei as emoções porque eu tô
me sentindo com raiva e irritada amorosa
apaixonada qualquer tipo de sensação
sentindo mas será mesmo que você a sua
emoção porque se ela é tão volátil e
flui
logo você desapareceria também então eu
aprendi a gente não é o nosso corpo não
somos a nossa mente e nem as nossas
emoções
então quem é você
é uma pergunta muito difícil de
responder
quando se vive no superficial
quando você começa a olhar ea observar o
fluxo da sua vida você vê que vive numa
agitação muito intensa e não tem como
uma mente rápida absorção
ver uma coisa sutil o que a gente pensa
de maneira grosseira a gente sente de
maneira grosseira
vamos pensar numa situação
a grande raiz do nosso sofrimento
são duas vertentes o gosto ou não gosto
por exemplo eu adoro brigadeiro mas hoje
tem mas ande sobremesa
op sofrimento estou sofrendo porque eu
gosto de uma coisa que eu não tenho
logo eu mesma criei esse sofrimento ele
não existe fui eu que criei
mas se tiver brigadeiro o brigadeiro vou
comer cabocó quero outro sofrimento
gerei uma expectativa em cima daquilo
que não existe mais
eu não gosto
a grande maioria das pessoas não gostam
de barata vamos tomar como exemplo
barata lo e aí o nosso pensamento comum
vem na seqüência do outro logo vence
esta barata colar em ela vai subir no
meu cabelo e aí cadê o chinelo tem que
matar essa barata sofrimento sofrimento
sofrimento e você está nesse lupi mental
e nem se tocou que nem família baratas a
mais ali ou não é que ela já assumiu não
existe duas formas de sofrer porque se
apega algo ou porque não se apega tem
uma aversão de outra coisa
e como você começa a se aprofundar um
pouco mais nisso a entrar um pouco mais
na sua mente você já observou que ela
vem numa maneira entrecortada e que você
não sabe muito bem como isso
funciona a macho disso
isso funciona porque a gente sofre por
duas questões gosto ou não gosto da ebay
e um pouco mais para baixo ainda que
quando você gera um pensamento perante o
seu ambiente operante uma experiência
que você já teve esse pensamento está
correlacionado com uma freqüência que
nem já dizia aí que na bíblia que no
início era tudo era o verbo
então você tem um som uma freqüência e
uma cor e tudo isso se transforma em
algo maior e quando isso se transforme
em algo maior você vibra numa região
específica do seu corpo como por exemplo
pessoas que sentem muita raiva a
propensão dessas pessoas é ter problemas
no estômago porque o pensamento da raiva
a mente da raiva localizada nessa região
pessoas que sentem medo como eu contei
para vocês do prédio sem problemas nesta
região e não somente ela está
distribuída durante nosso tronco todo e
cada novo pensamento que surge traz pra
gente uma sensação e essa sensação você
caracteriza a ela como gosta ou como não
gosta mas ao invés de viver uma única
vez é essa situação você entra num
looping mental e começa a repetir várias
vezes o assunto correlacionado um
diálogo interno que você conta e
responde para você mesmo e aí eu comecei
a entender que tudo o que eu estava
vivendo antes de ser doente de ser
expressada de ter problemas em
relacionamentos a culpar a minha mesmo
porque a gente que escolhe viver a nossa
vida do jeito que ela deve ser
independente tem consciência ou não
sobre isso é você que escolhe
eu queria convidar vocês para fazer uma
prática para entender sobre esse assunto
que é meio complexo de ser dito por
palavras ele é mais fácil de ser
compreendido com experiência com a
colaboração de todo mundo tem sido um
jeito confortável fecha seus olhos e
agora faça uma respiração bem profunda
respire fundo
solte relaxa as suas pernas
na próxima e inspiração tommy um pouco
mais de ar e relaxa seu quadril
inspire exale soltando todo seu tronco
inclusive os ombros
relaxa os braços e as mãos
saúde o seu pescoço e na nuca
seu rosto ea sua cabeça mas um jeito que
você fique com boa postura e apenas a
musculatura som tem relaxar
[Música]
é assim que a gente consegue aprofundar
um pouco mais novos e um desapego do
corpo de poder observar que se você
observa seu corpo você não é o que você
solta o seu corpo
veja que se algum pensamento vier na sua
mente como se fosse um cinema tem uma
tela mental e se eu falar para você
pensar num elefante amarelo
esse elefante apareceu nessa tela
você está assistindo o que está passando
na sua mente você tá fora da mente
então você não ela perceba que com
treinamento respiratório de soltar o ar
de vagar se acalmou sua emoção
se você a calma sua emoção
você também não é ela
sinta o seu corpo bem solto e
descontraída e se observe
observe que você pode mudar tudo aquilo
que está te incomodando
observe que você pode desacelerar seu
ritmo
[Música]
observe que você pode ter controle sobre
tudo isso que você orienta
então respire fundo novamente e abra
seus olhos e agora vou perguntar
novamente
quem é você você é observador
você não é apenas como se fosse um
funcionário da empresa
você não é o corpo que dói você não é a
mente agitada
você não é emoção dolorida você é quem
tem domínio sobre todas essas coisas e
tudo que está relacionado na sua vida
hoje é bom ou ruim é porque você criou
de alguma forma porque você deixou de
observar pode parecer assustador mas
também é muito libertador porque quando
você sabe que você é quem você observa
você toma rédea da sua vida
controla seu corpo controla sua emoção
controla sua mente e pode fazer e co
criar sua vida do jeito que você
gostaria que ela fosse
o yoga a gente tem um cumprimento final
é o chamado namastê
quando a gente reconhece que somos
observadores é como se a gente descobrir
se o nosso verdadeiro centro
e se dentro de mim existe um verdadeiro
centro dentro de você
também existe em um ato de paz de mãos
unidas no centro do peito do meu
verdadeiro sempre eu respeito e
reverencio o seu verdadeiro centro
namastê
e assim que eu mudei a minha vida
obrigado
[Aplausos]